[Music]
with me from the ball in the bullet the
weapon of choice is my politics it is it
evaded study but walls are in people's
minds so much stuff it happens here and
I return to communities I wouldn't hunt
and leafy suburbia it has risen from the
ashes most of it changed beyond
recognition on the banks of the Lagon
they went from building ships to
building peace but scratched the surface
and you find something else a city still
divided by walls 99 of them streets
still segregated by bricks mortar and
religion in some parts they lock the
gates each evening between Catholics and
Protestants and despite assumptions our
exclusive poll has find that young
people are just as divided as the older
generation this is the story of Belfast
today 20 years after the Good Friday
Agreement they police the pace lines
between the two communities in these
armored vehicles the threat of attack
here is still deemed severe North and
West Belfast are the most challenging
the most dangerous parts of this city
and that's where we're going on patrol
with the Police Service of Northern
Ireland policing was and still is a
significant issue here the old Royal
Ulster Constabulary has long been
replaced but these streets are still
heavily policed they did with different
issues now drugs mental illness suicide
communities haunted by the past
sergeant Craig McDowell has been a
police officer for the best part of 30
years every family problem in this area
not far
having one summer he's been involved in
trouble so be it calve injured or being
a fault and killing or injuring somebody
again I suppose dad's community so that
pocket to always be there he'll go away
they'll never go away the hopes and
dreams of a shared future are far from
the modern reality one side marches for
a united Ireland the other marches to
remain in the United Kingdom pollsters
from Sky data asked a representative
sample of the public here for their
honest assessment
so how has life changed
61% feels safer than they did 20 years
ago but 51% still say most or all of
their friends are of the same religion
and 23 percent never expect power
sharing to be restored Julianne is a
loyalist a chance meeting set her on a
path to the City Council
she says forcing enemies to share power
deprived this place of genuine
reconciliation with Mary from the ball
in the ballot the weapon of choice is my
politics and politics as you know
affects everyone's day until a life
affects the community and affects things
such as the scales obviously in their
their health and people fate of that
we're still very much at war its
sectarianism
a generational thing will Northern
Ireland eventually I'd live it know the
legacy of our conflict has very much
been or passed it is our present and it
will be our future until such times we
address it we asked people if they
thought sectarianism had gone away 51%
feel it is less divided in Northern
Ireland than it was 20 years ago but 24%
think it is more divided now and brags
it's making that more pronounced half
think it has deepened division Maggie
says she wants to move on but count it's
47 years since her mother and aunt were
shot dead by British soldiers in
we must have been really hopeful when
the agreement was signed that Northern
Ireland would leave all of that behind
that your that your children and
grandchildren would grow up in a
different environment I thought that
what that was definitely my hope but in
the meantime I so I am still back in
1871 I can't move forward we need I need
the truth I need people to know that my
mommy and my aunt Dorothy were not
terrorists and did not shake out of the
car and were killed in cold blood do you
think brexit has added to the sense of
division yep absolutely absolutely it's
gonna start a fire up all these emotions
people are gonna get frustrated and I
have to fade off for the month of a
better word the trouble starting again I
couldn't go through all that again I
don't think it's far so there's another
divider in Plano but tourists can't take
pictures of the invisible Irish border
almost every Catholic we polled opposes
border controls between Northern Ireland
and the Republic but the majority of
Protestants we polled oppose them in the
art of sea walls are in people's minds
if we don't try to break lambda we never
want to break the bricks and morter done
Jim was convicted of attempting to
murder a policeman a former IRA prisoner
he grew up in Bali Murphy a Republican
Heartland this is the police station
here you can see now that's the front of
it and you have a Catholic community
lives here and you can see the lengths
that this goes and you can see the the
way that it's monitored why why is all
that money being spent on the security
look it's we're still going we're still
seeing the size of the security
apparatus
well fast hasn't had its Berlin Wall
moment Tom Lee a Protestant has lived in
the shadow of the barricades for decades
that's where Jean McConville was
abducted but he says there's more
tension within each community now than
between them turf wars between drug
dealers
drug scenes get better Honda be honest
heroin cocaine you name it they're all
on the street you talk about people who
prey on the vulnerable are you talking
about former paramilitaries more Moya
used to say the dogs in the street know
what's going on in our areas and we know
what's going on in her areas criminality
there's no such thing as defendant our
communities that's a lot of nonsense
they're destroying our communities you
know the kids are dying and their
families are cracking up because of
what's harming our sea I mean there are
summer stuff that happens here and our
communities I wouldn't happen and leafy
suburbia let me assure you and that's
the real legacy of the trebles drugs
mental illness and suicide the number of
people taking their own lives has risen
by a third in the last 20 years more
people have died by suicide since the
agreement than were killed during 30
years of violence Jim was released from
prison early under the terms of the
agreement he now works with young people
across the city well there's a there's a
thing called trans generational trauma
which is very prevalent than my opinion
and in today's society you can't go
through 30 years of conflict I want to
say conflict I mean 30 years of war
there was a war on our streets Belfast
was a war zone and the parts that would
have been more shall' would have been
the parts that you know either socially
depraved areas of Belfast boxing rescued
Dean from the margins his sister was
knocked down and killed by a stolen car
three of his brothers died by suicide
his fiancee also took her own life she
was far more than sorry Bob we'll just
so she was given Authority
they they could have an average person
on the street but my thought she had she
was ill she was enough hope you shoulda
had mental health problems
what am i younger brothers box for me
yes well that's why I took this one if
he used to box me I used to do
everything guy he's like we were going
to spores for repairs me it's sober
teens quitter is an Indian man he would
have to be given given the issues that
he's fierce to over the years there's
lots of other young people over here are
the CM we have to try and look at the
real issues that young people are doing
a must we've got a dispute about Bragg's
it we've got the breakdown of power
sharing at Stormont we've got a wall
between two communities here all things
have been broken doesn't look at doors
and it seems very pessimistic but the
end of the day I had they get off in the
morning I have to make sure I've got
enough money to feed the kids make sure
my house is right I got my rent for the
house or whatever car patronymic er I
don't get that they worried about the
wall up and breaks it Mike : I'm worried
very personal eggs no come from well a
lot of people are like that
Julianne breaks one stereotype
she's a loyalist in a sim sex civil
partnership a mother of six month-old
twins how difficult was it for you
coming out in your community common
it--with in my community there was no
you know grand unveiling of the new
Julian or anything and people really
didn't bat an eyelid at all you know we
have two political parties at the head
of our government one who is very
staunchly unionist and wants to mattina
protecting Union and the other wants to
destroy it
yeah one wants to unite the island and
wonder one form of governance and and so
whilst that access the social issues
don't necessarily feature I think the
entire community has a choice in
religion whether your practice or not
we're all stumped at birth yes we all
have our religion from birth so our
attitudes changing on some issues 76%
wants same-sex marriage introduced in
Northern Ireland fifty-four percent
support unrestricted access to abortion
for women up to 12 weeks pregnant and 69
percent believe all schools should be
integrated
Catholics and Protestants were just to
seeing people we've both grown open the
same type of situations and stuff so the
younger people are our next generation
coming up so they are instead of it
doesn't matter it really goes a mother
borough seeing paper so we are it we are
always here every morning they reopen
the kids people travel freely again from
one side to the other but until they're
open permanently the new dome they were
promised here cannot break we're going
to you so much but lonely places for
police officers although they are from
the community we're still human beings
and they are city's most important thing
cancer still numberland original number
cars stole wearing flak jackets were so
kind of gone so they still have guns but
they don't have a power-sharing
government belfast may have changed but
not to the point where things are normal
here
this is no-man's land the face between
Protestant homes on one side and
Catholic homes on the other
it's the moderate voice of the middle
grind that's been dried out here lost
some say in a system of government that
has kept the peace but kept the walls
too
[Music]